the realm
do you know what the realm is
it's the thousand blades of aegon's
enemies
a story we agreed to tell each other
over
and over till we forget that it's a lie
what's up ladies and gentlemen welcome
back for another house of the dragon
update video in this video i want to
show you some of the new information
that was revealed about house of the
dragon during a recent interview with
one of the showrunners miguel sapochnick
now for those of you who might not know
miguel sapochnick is famously known for
directing some of game of thrones
greatest episodes like hardhome battle
of the bastards and the winds of winter
after game of thrones ended hbo brought
him on to be one of house of the dragon
showrunners alongside one of its
co-creators ryan condol during this
interview miguel was asked about how
house of the dragon will be different
from game of thrones let me show you
what he said
i think we were very respectful of what
the original show is said saparchnick
who directs multiple episodes of house
of the dragon and also serves as
showrunner alongside the series
co-creator ryan condell it wasn't broken
so we're not trying to reinvent the
wheel house of the dragon has its own
tone that will evolve and emerge over
the course of the show but first it's
very important for us to pay respects
and homage to the original series which
was groundbreaking we are standing on
the shoulders of that show and we're
only here because of that show so the
most important thing for us to do is to
respect that show as much as possible
and try to compliment it rather than
reinvent it and i was involved in making
the original show so i feel like that's
been useful like i'm not arriving going
let's do everything different that said
we can say well when we did thrones we
did it this way he added if you start
every sentence with that you've lost
this is something else and it should be
something else it's a different crew
different people different tone
hopefully it will be seen as something
else but it will have to earn that it
won't happen overnight hopefully fans
will enjoy this for the thing that it is
we'll be lucky if we ever come close to
what the original show was so we're
putting our heads down and getting on
with it and hoping that we come up with
something that is worthy of having a
game of thrones title it's a lot of work
sapochnick said it's a pretty
interesting shift i'm producing other
directors and getting involved in a lot
of the minutia i feel vaguely elated on
my directing days because i don't have
to think about anything other than
directing i've also learned as i've
learned on finch that it's becoming more
and more important to me as i'm getting
older to work with people that i like
alright now i want to show you what some
of the old game of thrones actors had to
say about house of the dragon nikolai
callster waldow also known as jamie
lannister also gave some of his thoughts
about house of the dragon during one of
his recent interviews he said i saw the
teaser trailer that they came out with
and i was intrigued i thought it was fun
to see matt smith in that world and in
that beautiful white wig and listen i'm
curious as everyone but it is a
different show it's its own show i just
hope it's great i hope the success of
game of thrones won't get in the way for
people when they experience this new
show for us it took a while for people
to get into game of thrones i remember
the first season people were saying
there are too many characters i don't
know what's happening i don't think they
have the luxury we had they have to
start with where we were in like season
4 or 5 because that's what they will be
compared to but i really hope that it's
a massive hit for them
kit harrington also known as jon snow
gave some of his thoughts about house of
the dragon as well he said it's being
written and produced and run by a very
good friend of mine miguel sapochnick
who directed me in the original thrones
he said it might be painful to watch you
know i think there's so much tied up in
that that i might find it hard but i
would like to watch it and support him
and support his work and i wish them the
best with that
so as you can see none of this is really
groundbreaking news but i did still find
it to be interesting nonetheless i
always like hearing from some of my
favorite characters from game of thrones
it was also nice to finally hear miguel
sapochnick say a few things about
working on house of the dragon one of
the most exciting things about this new
show is learning that he will definitely
be directing some of the episodes in the
first season this has me very happy
because as i said before miguel has
directed some of game of thrones
greatest episodes knowing that he will
do some of the heavy lifting in the
first season of this new show only sets
them up for success even more he wasn't
directing any episodes on game of
thrones until season 5 but now he will
be hands-on with house of the dragon
from the very beginning which i think is
great now there have also been a lot of
new set photos that i have seen online
let me know if you would like me to make
a video about those they may reveal some
more information about some of the
scenes we will see in this first season
as always i want to thank everyone for
watching this video i hope you all have
a great day i will see you again very
soon
bye
[Music]
[Music]
you